welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of brick
and Morty season 7 episode 3 Air Force
Wong a play on the 1997 Harrison Ford
film Air Force 1 where a president with
low approval ratings turns into an
action hero to win the public back and
lives on as a proof of concept for
Harrison Ford to return as the president
of the MCU in Captain America 4 even
though Air Force 1 has the worst age CGI
airplane crash the climactic scene let's
break down all the Easter eggs the
inside jokes the animation details that
you might have missed in this episode of
Rick and Morty and if you're in the LA
area new rockstars is going to be doing
a live show on November 16th at brain
dead Studios come hang out with me and
with Tommy and others in the new
Rockstar team ticket info in the
description the episode opens in therapy
with Dr Wong voiced by Susan sandon
returning from the pickle Rick episode
of season 3 Rick's emotional progress is
really at the center of this episode our
man is growing she asks though if he is
a hologram he is but he's actually just
under the couch retrieving a bag of
funions that he left there last week so
while it seems at first like he's been
using Holograms to fill in for these
sessions the fact that he was there last
week shows that he has been coming to
therapy regularly which is such good
news it's actually pretty funny to me
that the opening line of this episode is
before we move off this topic can I ask
if you're currently a hologram so they
were in mid conversation she was talking
to a hologram and began to suspect that
something was off and the whole time
they were having that conversation Rick
was behind the couch looking for those
funions but Rick gets a call from
president Curtis brilliantly voiced by
Keith David who has returned in at least
one episode per season ever since get
Swifty in season 2 but I would say this
right here is the first time the show
deconstructs his and Rick's
transactional relationship in a way that
weaves the president into the Mythos of
the show and how perfect is it that he
comes into contact with unity a concept
based at least in part on John
Carpenter's 1982 the thing which many
view as Keith David's breakout role the
president explains in 1961 the CIA
secretly relocated the loch nest monster
to Lake Erie and replaced her bones with
titanium she was then bit by several
whale wolves giving us the Ultimate
anti-submarine Weapon but the Soviets
smuggled in a leprechaun who turned
nessie's bones into silver giving her
the wear version of AIDS she sank to the
bottom and we assumed she was dead but
she was only asleep now she's awake and
hungry it's all very stupid and seems to
be kind of like a Godzilla Kaiju
situation but a 1961 CIA operation
totally recalls the Bay of Pigs invasion
in Cuba in April 1961 that was the
failed CIA plot to overthrow Fidel
Castro an embarrassment at JFK even
though that mission was planned before
he took office but this whole Nessie
operation makes it seem like the Bay of
Pigs was like a false flag to distract
from the real plan to turn Nessie into a
ridiculous weapon to combat Soviet subs
and yeah using titanium bones for Nessie
a very possible nod to The Weapon X
Program of giving Wolverine an
adamantium skeleton and this is just two
episodes after the show's Hugh Jackman
season premiere that said that that
would kill all the future Wolverine
references we didn't make it that long I
just love this idea though that the
Americans used a Scottish folklore
creature while the Soviets used Irish
folklore of leprechauns and this would
be in the 1960s the decade when the
troubles began in Northern Ireland like
the KGB might have used that political
Strife to get the Irish to strike
against NATO allies but I guess that
would all be a Prelude to another
Harrison Ford political thriller Patriot
Games I clearly grew up in a Tom Clancy
family and I don't apologize for that
now during all of this while everyone
else in the helicopter is holding on to
the straps for stability Rick casually
leans back and just munchs on funions
holding on to nothing because he is the
most experienced person in the universe
when it comes to staying level reminding
us of one of my favorite cutaways from
Morty's mindblowers perfect level LS to
the cosmic Slaughter we learned the
president is into Dr Wong and we also
learned that his bodyguard is a
Scientologist don't be a space Mormon
why not it's silly sorry it's a cheap
shot worship how you
want I like Tom Cruz yeah this is kind
of an inside joke among Hollywood comedy
writers that everyone knows Scientology
is a cult but everyone is also afraid to
go too hard against them because
surprisingly a ton of very powerful
people in the industry still have ties
to the church Church from Tom Cruz to
John Travolta to Elizabeth Moss Will
Smith has denied it remember South Park
went after the church in its famous tra
in the closet 2005 episode but the
Simpsons can't really make Scientology
jokes because Nancy cartright is a
Scientologist really to spend enough
time in Los Angeles you'll be amazed how
entrenched it is like take classes at
UCB right across the street is a
celebrity center and everyone who's mad
at UCB for not putting them on a Herald
team is very quick to say oh Scientology
owns elas to the Franklin theater and
that's why they had to take down that
one sketch that lyan taking classes at
UCB with be part of Scientology and it's
hilarious for me to talk about it
because the entire new Rockstar sales
team is made up of former artistic
directors of Los Angeles comedy theaters
so Rick and Morty watch Mr stabby on
interdimensional cable Mr stabby has
swords for Limbs and a sword nose why do
people get tickets to his tapings it's a
Fame obsessed culture yes the obsession
with Fame and with cult of personality
is the deeper theme of this episode also
this gag reminds me of my all-time
favorite Simpsons bit Gentle Ben let's
have less hom Simpsons and more money
for public schools
Ben I have a
question no Ben
no the president summons Rick again
we've got a situation in the state of
Virginia Bigfoot that's Montana Nazis
that's of everywhere according to
Bigfoot field researchers organization
there have been 53 credible Bigfoot
sightings in Montana where Virginia has
86 so not a far off guess from Rick for
what it's worth Washington State leads
the pack with 713 and yeah reference to
Nazis in Virginia and Nazis being
everywhere nod to the Charlottesville
events of 2017 an event that many sadly
like the president's General here
excused as very fine people being on
both sides the president brings up
Virginia's State slogan Virginia is for
Lovers and the state actually adopted
this slogan in 1969 appropriate because
this was a summer of love and you know
69 is a sex number the slogan was
actually created to attract young people
to the state and has graced millions of
ironic t-shirts over the years but
Virginia here has declared itself
exclusively for lovers the screen shows
everyone kissing and the bus reads next
stop love and since I made fun of a UCB
in the LA comedy community a moment ago
I got a shout out Comedy Bang Bang and
Drew tarver's hilarious Martin Sheffield
lickly bit which this absolutely
reminded me of all aboard the train of
love we're going full steam ahead choo
choo the Caboose is full of broken
hearts and the conductor is a kid yes
but the president is suspicious of
anything with 100% approval rating
America knows and incinerates a coat
when it sees one yes a very dark
reference to the Waco Siege where a cult
standoff between the branched vians and
government agents ended in a deadly fire
so we meet the dream team of Fleet flap
who might be able to tell the future
Onyx a rock creature who's apparently a
Weapon Specialist in Chi-Chi a smart
fridge lookin supercomputer whose name
is written as Chi Squared but flip flaps
possibly prophetic drawings recall the
guy from Heroes who could paint things
that end up happening in the future and
like the kid in every horror movie but
they draw Rick being mauled by Bigfoot
and let's see what happens later this
season because I would love to see this
payoff later down the line the Virginia
governor says but the rest of your
country doesn't need Virginia's love
right now you know the last time a state
talked that way we had to have a whole
thing yes to reminder that Virginia
cited with the Confederacy in the
American Civil War and General Robert E
Lee formerly surrendered to the Union
Army at the atics courthouse in the
state of Virginia while Rick had the
president Sav his phone with a
presidential seal the president saves
Rick as Rick goddamn Spaceman with a
photo of the two of them posing in front
of the loch nest monster apparently they
caught it just with a fishing rod that's
all it took but I love this detail
because remember at the end of season 3
episode 10 after Rick's brawl with the
president Rick returns as fly fishing
Rick claiming to be a different Rick and
uses that to repair his friendship with
the president so I just love this idea
that Rick maybe keeping up this ruse and
only helps the president in ways that
involve fishing the governor's tour of
the utopian Virginia reminds me a lot of
like anytime we saw a new community in
the Walking Dead Season 6 like whether
it was Alexandria or Jeffrey showing his
farm community but this leads to the
president calling them communist
bastards but then he changes his tone
all goods are freely given communist
bastards and all goods are freely made
communist bastards yeah the tone shifts
to positive which might just be how like
politicians respect the American
tradition of farming in the abstract but
scowl when you know they can't find a
way to tax and profit off of the farming
but the cultists begin vomiting to
assimilate them finally your religion
comes in handy no my only chance at
meeting Will Smith okay so Will Smith
let's be clear about this while Will and
Jada have denied being scientologists
according to the Daily Beast they did
use one of their residences as a base
for a school that the former Headmaster
of said was a Scientology Academy like
elron hubt was in the curriculum there
were pictures of Elon hovered up around
so this just what they said also Leah
Remy said that she would often see Jada
pingin Smith at the scentology celebrity
center you know the one across the
street from UCB and Jada has said that
she studied dianic but was not a
Scientologist so make of that what you
will but either way I just think it's
hilarious that the president of the
United States thinks that this would be
his only way of meeting Will Smith
despite earlier saying he could pull up
everyone's genome now long time new
rockstars viewers know how much we use
geology and how long we've been using it
for but if this is your first time
hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality Skin Care on a
student film budget geology is a 23 time
award winning skin hair and bodycare
Company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100 100% off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body
products when you add it to your trial
it's truly a wild offer one of the best
they've ever given our audience so click
the link in the description or go to GE
log. i/ rockstars 100 to get started
Rick recognizes this as the doing of
unity the hide mind Voice by Christina
Hendrick that's one part John Carpenter
is a thing but also with her space
station is absolutely a take on the Borg
hive mind from Star Trek she was first
introduced in season 2 episode 3
autoerotic assimilation and Rick's whole
history with unity I and others have
argued in the past mirrors Dan Harmon's
history with the NBC sitcom Community
which gets a shout out in that season 2
episode but the fact that Rick now has
his defense against Unity ready to go
shows us he's still been thinking about
them in the past since their breakup
Rick calls his defense separation
obviously the opposite of the word unity
and by the way for what might be the
most in-depth Deep dive on John
Carpenter thing and some hot takes that
the alien entity in that movie is a
communion seeking protagonist who views
mccre the Rick of that story as the
cancerous toxin check out my analysis on
the Deep dive Channel which is now live
for you to watch and enjoy so earlier
Rick told Unity that Dr Wong was part
nutritionist so later when Dr Wong
starts going off about being a
nutritionist that's how Rick knows that
she was assimilated so we learn that
Unity is doing this though because she
is worried that Rick is looking for him
after he almost died last time referring
of course to Rick's renewed search for
Rick Prime the Rick who killed his
family a plot point that came back at
the the end of season 5 and continued
through season 6 and in these little
background details throughout season 7
but the president activates a dome
around the entire state of Virginia
Virginia is not Dome shaped but I guess
somehow it just kind of works with the
Virginia borders putting a dome over a
residential area this happens to
Springfield and The Simpsons Movie and
in the Stephen King story turn CBS
series Under the Dome the Dome emits
from an orb that rises out of the
Virginia Washington Monument in the city
of Richmond in the Public Square the
statute pictures George Washington at
the center and then around him Thomas
Jefferson Patrick Henry Andrew Lewis
Johan Marshall George Mason and Thomas
Nelson Jr all them Founding Father
Virginia the news anchor Shonda
criticizes the president this president
has been in office for how many alien
invasions not to mention the mutant
turkeys the abandoned White House
orbiting our planet the eco-conscious
dinosaurs yes she's referencing season 5
episode 6 Rick and Morty's than
exploitation spectacular season 6
episode 10 rical Mortons rickm Miss Mort
and season 6 episode 6 J Rick s Mort
Rick ejects all of his go- go gadget
weapons at once we see a boxing glove on
a spring a kind of boomerang an energy
blade and then a ballot and I believe on
the front of it it says recall
referendum which would be a great
anti-politician weapon however Federal
elected officials like the president
cannot be recalled by popular vote they
can only be impeached or just lose
re-election or like die in office
recalls are only in effect for certain
States for like Statewide offices like
Governor State legislators things like
that Unity calls to warn that the people
in the dome are cut off from her and
thus vulnerable to another mine to form
a new Colony splintered off from her and
Rick makes fun of her for needing a
PowerPoint and I just appreciate the
meta joke from the writers here because
the writers probably felt like we the
viewers needed a visual aid to
understand how the president could take
control of these masses later and they
just kind of hang a lantern on it here
Rick tells Unity I'm sorry you lost a
finger but that's the price of surprise
butt play as in I'm sorry to cut off
your limb of high mind members but you
stuck up on me in this orgy pile and I
also wonder what interner species ories
Rick would have been in in the past
where participants lost a finger that
way like some butt head teeth Dr Wong
dumps the president and he doesn't take
it well there's an exit tunnel by the
lady's room it gets lots of use and not
just by sex workers yes I call back to
the Kennedy sex tunnels in the McKinley
hooker dump that the president
referenced in season 3 episode 10 Rick
yells at summer when's the last time you
saw your therapist today well then she
sucks no stop yelling at me I need
boundaries yeah Rick is incorporating
therapy lingo into his everyday life and
he does apologize after she slams the
door later he'll tell summer that he did
Apologize he just did it quietly but
this moment reminded me of that debate
earlier last summer around Jonah Hill
using therapy speak and specifically the
word boundaries in a very messy context
like look therapy is good but just
because someone goes to therapy and
talks about going to therapy a lot
doesn't mean that they're not still
capable of continuing to hurt people and
they don't get a free pass just because
they went to therapy the news zooms into
on the president insecurely watching
himself on the news live this no amount
of spectacle is going to undo his last
debacle sh not Shanda she hates me I
love how they put a slight delay on his
lips moving on the news on his phone as
it would have a delay in real life so
the president bails on his plan once he
realizes that he can get a 100% approval
rating if he turns America into a hive
mind he eats their puke
holy yeah because the president is
still adjusting to running a hive mind
he can't yet speak through one drone at
a time and he just kind of has to speak
in PA mode but this part of the episode
is why it's my favorite exploration of
the president character on Rick and
Morty so far because he not just a
one-off joke about his ego or his
rivalry with Ricks I see your ass is
playing Minecraft I got you on satellite
or the United States military-industrial
complex but the way modern presidents
and Seekers of the presidency have been
so insecure addicted to validation
obsessed with social media like
presidents Now operate as cult leaders
who want electoral maps to be solidly
100% their party's color when that is
never going to happen and I don't think
from here forward we're ever going to
see that again in our lifetimes we are
in such a polarized time and there's
seems to be something really really
scary about presidents having
smartphones and personal Twitter
accounts and I love they choose Virginia
as a setting it works especially well
for this whole social experiment because
while the state of Virginia has started
to lean blue in certain recent election
Cycles they also most recently elected a
republican Governor it's still
considered a swing state with a mix of
conservative and liberal voters and
you're just never going to get 100%
approval for any political leader in the
state of Virginia and maybe it's on the
nose but I love how this Conformity is
spread person to person by vomiting into
each other's mouths the puke in this
case is a duller shade than unities was
and it shows how this High mind support
of any political movement it's just a
spewing the worst of ourselves into each
other Rick tells the kids you kid stay
inside and lock up Dad's still out
shopping then stay inside lock up and
plug your ears remember in season 3
episode 5 Rick locked down the house and
Jerry was left outside in the yard as Dr
Wong goes down this road among the
fleeing people is a mom who takes her
baby out of the back seat but there is
no car seat and one of the guys who
swarms the car has a 69 shirt as his
high mind is a big Pro president orgy
aboard Unity ship we see a bunch of
alien crew members that are all part of
unity if you look closely notice they
are all blinking in unison very creepy
but awesome attention to detail these
aliens include a few zerian from season
1 episode 4 along with that big red
alien in the T-shirt who said that Rick
was taking Roy Off the Grid in Morty
night run holy this guy's taking
Roy Off the Grid and later we see a
tuskfish alien species that's known as
the smans unity's fleet approaches
Manhattan St Louis Hollywood and San
Francisco in Vegas on the luxer casino
sign we see ads for what looks like the
Blue Man Group and the amazing Jonathan
a hilarious comedy magician who died
last year now the Blue Man Group is
currently playing at the luxer as is
katop who you know what is actually
really funny live Unity releases
everyone on Earth from the collective
and it's just painful for her and for
everyone as detoxing from high mind
thinking back to your own thoughts can
really be a difficult transition it's
just so sad to see everyone immediately
revert to their phones and road rage and
BuzzFeed clickbait articles top 10
literally popular things to lowkey love
after Unity says she doesn't trust Rick
he returns to the garage and grabs some
foamies from his fridge inside that
fridge are a few other snacks like some
slime colored eggs an alien eyeball and
I'm thinking individually package
pickles in case he ever wanted to ditch
therapy again I'm pickle Rick though he
apparently has not so good on him also
on the Shelf is that Doc Brown style
colander with a mind switching headgear
from last episode Rick listens to
unity's voicemails that recalls Jerry's
answering machine from season 3 episode
9 because who really has just answering
machines anymore and we end with a
cheerfully threatening message from
David mavage head of the Church of
Scientology hey Rick David miscavage
here heard you were saying some really
great things about scientology if you
ever want to meet Travolta and Playback
we don't want to meet Travolta but
where's Shelly now in the post-edit
scene Mr stabby is being interviewed by
Gary an alien version of Larry King now
Mr stabby is voiced by legendary voice
actor SpongeBob SquarePants Tom Kenny
your show has resulted in the deaths of
58,000 attendees well you're talking
about it but I love this line it's a
perfect summation for the deeper theme
of this episode how the masses are just
going to inexplicably flock toward
things that will hurt them please
support us by grabbing one of these Loki
inspired shirts we're all going to die
from nerd r. shop see you all in Los
Angeles for our live show on November
16th big thanks to Jordan Morris for his
help with writing this breakdown
subscribe to all three of our channels
follow me at eaos thanks for watching
I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye
oh